here's the televised mental institution  MSNBC with racist Joy Reed and she  actually aired a clip of drag queen  Story Hour and I don't think this  segment went exactly how she intended I  think most people have ever seen one  I've been to one with kids there with  like kids there I want to show you guys  what drag queen story hours look like no  God please no the hair on the drag queen  goes up up up up up up up up up up up up  up up  what you saw there was a dude dressed up  as a chick  I was told by Joy Reed that that's a  drag queen not a trans person so that is  a guy who identifies as a guy who  dresses up like a chicken for some  reason wants to read children's stories  to children and why would you want a  five-year-old to have to look at that  thing and think about what is going on  here